sind das bloß drohgebärden oder steht
europa vor einem krieg in der sache geht
es um nichts weniger als den erhalt der
europäischen friedensordnung und
waffen bild deutschland dafür keine
liefern
die bundesregierung hat in den letzten
jahren immer wieder entschieden keine
legalen waffen zu liefern dafür gibt es
gründe die sich auch natürlich aus der
ganzen entwicklung der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte speisen die bundesregierung
will russland nicht unnötig provozieren
der größte bündnispartner konsterniert
die idee dass die versorgung der ukraine
mit verteidigungswaffen durch die usa
einzelne eu staaten und die nato denn
irgendeiner weise russische aggression
provoziere stellt die tatsachen auf den
kopf
für die ukraine geht um alles einmal
mehr in der geschichte fühlt sich das
land im stich gelassen
gerade jetzt
diese moment der wahrheit gekommen ist
wo viele menschen in meiner heimat
sehen und feststellen also wer der wahre
der treue freund und partner ist während
deutschland den dissens mit den
bündnispartnern in kauf nimmt schafft
russland fakten und verlegt immer mehr
truppen in richtung ukraine
frei zugängliche satellitenbilder lassen
daran keinen zweifel
kriegs bereit aufgereiht hunderte panzer
artillerie geschosse haubitzen
aber auch unterkünfte kantinen
krankenstationen für inzwischen über
120.000 soldaten und kapazitäten für
viele mehr
der polnische militär analyst konrad
musiker hat die karten erstellt und
ausgewertet
die aktuellsten bilder der maxa
satelliten sind ein paar tage alt und
zeigen dass sie einige zelte neuerdings
beheizt werden und wir sehen soldaten an
diesem zählt
alles was hier seit mitte oktober
militärisch passiert ist so beispiellos
und gigantisch dass man das nicht ein
verrat
musiker identifiziert
36 raketenabschussrampen vom typ
iskander mit über 500 kilometern
reichweite
außerdem tu es mehrfach raketenwerfer
besonders geeignet zur eroberung großer
städte und panzer vom typ t 90 des
weiteren eine starke luftwaffe dem hat
die ukrainische armee fast nichts
entgegenzusetzen
[Musik]
russland ist die weltgrößte atommacht
russland ist die bei weitem und mit
großem abstand größte militärmacht in
europa russland hat gegenüber jedem
staat in europa eskalation dominanz aber
russland sucht sich nur die kriege aus
die es auch berechenbar gewinnen kann
und an der berechenbarkeit kann man
immer noch ansetzen
darauf setzen unter anderem die
amerikaner aktuell vor allem mit
munition und einfachen panzer
abwehrsystemen für über 2,5 milliarden
dollar hat washington in den letzten
jahren waffen an kiew geliefert nicht in
dem glauben dass das land sich damit im
ernstfall retten kann sondern um den
preis für russland in die höhe zu
treiben und da sieht die ukraine auch
deutschland in der pflicht
da bräuchten wir natürlich entsprechende
systeme an die panzer
waffen raketen mit denen man keinen
angriffskrieg führen kann ja sondern man
kann sich verteidigen wenn man kann den
preis für diesen einmarsch in die höhe
treiben dasselbe gilt für die küste dass
man systeme hat und deutschland
ist einer der weltweit besten hersteller
von auch von von diesen waffensystemen
die zur verteidigung dienen kurzfristig
liefern könnte deutschland schnelle
kleine panzer oder auch die panzer
abwehr war für milan mit der berlin auch
schon die kurdische peschmerga im kampf
gegen denise unterstützt hat doch was
könnten diese waffen im ukraine konflikt
bewirken die ukraine ist nicht in der
lage sich militärisch gegenüber einem
russischen angriff zu verteidigen da
können wir so viele waffen einschieben
wie wir wollen das wird nicht gelingen
der ehemalige generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr ist gegen eine bewaffnung
auch weil es reine verteidigungswaffen
nicht gibt kujat fürchtet eskalation
durch provokation ich höre dass auch das
soll der abschreckung dienen aber es
dient nicht der abschreckung sondern es
bedeutet lediglich dass wir das risiko
dass es durch ein menschliches oder
technisches versagen ist dann doch zu
einem konflikt kommt dass sie dieses
risiko vergrößern auch dass wir
möglicherweise dadurch eine klare
einschätzung auf beiden seiten
verursachen die mit der realität nichts
zu tun hat in dieser sehr angespannten
situation passiert so etwas leicht die
realität der ukrainischen streitkräfte
sieht so aus kriegsmüde nach acht jahren
einsatz gegen separatisten im donbass in
dem die 200.000 mann starke armee bisher
kaum mehr als ein patt erreichen konnte
ich will dass das hier aufhört wir haben
einfach genug
dass diese männer nicht lange gegen
russland kämpfen werden das befürchtet
harald kujat
wir haben das gleiche gedacht
afghanistan wenn wir die afghanischen
streitkräfte so gut wie möglich
ausrüsten dem wir sie ausbilden dann
werden sie schon in der lage sein sich
gegen die taliban zu verteidigen das war
ein grosser irrtum und der ein oder
andere hat das auch frühzeitig gesagt
trotzdem hat man das gemacht und die
situation die dann entstanden ist ist
die mit dem was jetzt zu tun haben eine
riesengroße katastrophe ich denke dafür
sollten wir die ukraine bewahren
derweil versucht der creme die erzählung
in seine richtung zu drehen der westen
bewaffnet die ukraine sagt
putin-sprecher paskov die sich so die
abtrünnigen provinzen im donbass
zurückerobern wollen
[Musik]
jede einzelne waffe ob defensiv oder
offensiv nutzt den heißspornen in kiew
bei dieser operation
wir müssen darüber in sorge sein und
haben das lange kommen sehen
es wäre gut die nato staaten würden in
einer ihrer zahlreichen reden auf kiew
einwirken nicht mit waffen tatsachen zu
schaffen
die us geheimdienste dagegen erwarten
einen russischen angriff nach ihrer lage
einschätzung russland zunächst einen
landweg zur besetzten krim erobern und
anschließend den nordosten des landes
angreifen städte würden zunächst
möglicherweise eingekesselt wasser strom
und gas abgeschaltet da russland auch
truppen nach belarus verlegt hat ist von
hier aus in einer letzten phase ein
angriff auf kiew denkbar mit der ukraine
viele ein souveräner staat in europa das
zu verhindern so die lesart in den usa
sei auch eine deutsche aufgabe
es ist frustrierend dass deutschland
sich nicht zu waffenlieferungen
durchringt und keine aktive haltung
einnimmt
ich denke berlin ist die einzige
hauptstadt die wirklich einfluss auf den
kreml nehmen kann
und das wird nicht gelingen wenn
deutschland zum zuschauer wird
am abend ist präsident marc roth zu gast
bei kanzler scholz paris hat schon
waffen an kiew geliefert berlin will das
nicht doch dieser deutschen ostpolitik
will bisher kein wichtiger verbündeter
im westen folgen